in Alberta there were rallies in the
province's two largest cities to oppose
Premier Danielle Smith's sweeping new
regulations on gender identity her
policy will put thousands of Children at
Risk she will risk their health their
mental health and their very lives for
her own political
gamesmanship Alberta NDP leader Rachel
notley joined protesters in Edmonton who
rallied simultaneously with another
demonstration in Cal
both Gatherings expressing anger over
Smith's newly announced plan to restrict
important procedures for transgender
[Applause]
youth in Edmonton's old Strat Kona
neighborhood protesters made their
voices
clear protesters called on the province
to Ru back its proposed policies that
would affect student gender identity
access to gender affirming healthare and
sports 16-year-old J mcneel didn't think
she'd be here shouldn't have to like
have to protest a discriminatory bill
that's against the Charter of Rights and
Freedoms I shouldn't have to do that so
but I do so I'm here doing that she is
one transgender youth who will be
affected by these changes some of the
policies include requiring schools to
seek parental consent if their child
changes their name and pronouns the main
concern is the violence that comes with
being outed rileigh organizer Rowan
Morris part of trans y says the policy
put the safety of kids at risk he says
there's an assumption that home is a
safe space uh many people know that one
of the highest risks of outing these
youth is going to be that their parents
May reject them and kick them out when I
came out as trans I actually was
disowned by my family it is not just a
statistical anomaly it is an actual
thing that does happen to people NDP
leader Rachel notley spoke at Saturday's
rally we have a premier who had the
unmitigated G to go on TV and claim she
cares about the safety of kids while
then introducing a policy which is
design
to put them at risk in a statement The
Province says it is introducing these
policies to preserve choices youth make
before potentially making life-altering
and irreversible adult decisions it adds
the proposed changes will create new
supports for the transgender Community
including medical professionals
specializing in transgender care and
developing a counseling pilot for youth
I am really suspicious of that these
policies sound like they're like they do
kind of the opposite of like bringing in
supports and everything
McNeil says she's lucky her parents are
accepting of her so she can continue to
be who she is at school but she says
she'll keep fighting because she knows
that's not the same for everyone caby
Mal Darren Global News it's definitely a
showing of solidarity here in downtown
Calgary at City Hall as thousands have
come together in solidarity just days
after some controversial policies were
announced by the UCP government
impacting the
lgbtq2
community
now this is a response to Wednesday's
Announcement by Alberta Premier Daniel
Smith and her government's proposed plan
those with lived experience say these
policies will impact how they seek
Medical Treatments participate in
athletics and how they use preferred
pronouns in schools organizers of the
event are calling the policies absurd
and will permanently alter the lives of
countless people we're seeing sympathy
demonstrations solidarity demonstrations
in Ottawa and Toronto all across the
country as the entire Canadian country
is saying what is happening this is not
what we believe in uh so the goal today
is to shine light and to show policy
makers that this is not what people want
hopefully they abandon these terrible
policies I find it rather disgusting
that they're trying to take our away our
rights and I want to stand for what's
right we're not going to stand for
hatred that's a lot like this it's
hateful it's bigoted it's unnecessary
people were just feeling comfortable
especially here in Alberta it's very
hard to be like trans to being on binary
to be any of those things it's just I
don't know it makes me sad it makes me
feel horrible and I feel like a lot of
the these people feel the same
way now organizers say the event is also
helping to raise funds to support a
potential legal challenge in case these
policies become legislated Craig mney
Global News